setting off to court on Friday morning
Kem soccer knew that there would only be
one verdict the trial which has dragged
on for three years had seen many delays
but very little real evidence
nonetheless it was clear with elections
coming up cambodia's main opposition
leader was unlikely to walk free the
multi-year
-cated conspiracy is a miscarriage of
Justice a virgin of Cambodian politics
kamsaka's rise to the top started in
2012 when he joined forces with Sam
rainsy the other main opposition
politician the party they formed the
Cambodian National rescue party posed a
serious threat to the ruling Cambodian
People's Party in local and National
politics until it was dissolved in 2017.
at the time many party members were
jailed or fled the country like the
party's co-founder Sam rainsy
is very afraid of the opposition
especially he is afraid of the Cambodia
National rescue party
which is growing very popular it is why
he has to condemn the terms of car
hunson now the world's longest serving
prime minister has effectively been in
power since 1985. now he's preparing to
hand over control to his son the
Cambodian People's Party will contest
the general election in July but with
Kem sokha now permanently removed from
the political landscape there's very
little opposition
is a indicator of the death of democracy
what has happened to him shows that the
the Democratic aspirations that were
contained from untak on on you know when
the International Community came
together to sort of help reconstruct
Cambodia that Democratic dream has been
killed by hunson Kim soccer's legal
teams say they will appeal and there may
be the opportunities to negotiate a
reduction in sentence but that's
unlikely to happen until after the
elections and Hansen's confirmation of
another four years in power Tony Chang
Al Jazeera